how's it going bros this is Pierre 2pac  and please enjoy this exclusive teaser  of my new show scare PewDiePie daddy  please uh-huh I'd like you to come to  the baby  um I would not like to come to the  basement oh what the [ __ ]  [ __ ] yeah oh oh this is not cool man  are you kidding me right now  I'm so excited to finally tell you what  I've been working on we recorded a show  together with The Walking Dead called  scare PewDiePie it's me being put into  live horror scenarios like live horror  games I had no idea what was going to  happen and it was one of the craziest  experience of my life so I can't wait  for you Bros to see it this has been a  huge opportunity for me and it really  means a lot that you bros support it as  well  and I really really think you're gonna  enjoy it if you want to watch another  teaser trailer just wait for the outro  and that's all for now as always stay  awesome breasts I signed up for this so  I'm okay but really I'm not okay